so welcome to those of you that have
come along to the bioinformatics session
today my name is Robert flatman I'm a
biochemistry manager at a large private
pathology laboratory in Australia a
sonic want a member of the sonic
healthcare companies around the world I
should really declare upfront that I I
dabble in IT a lot so even though I'm a
biochemist I do a lot of computer work
developing new systems for our for our
laboratories but I also dabble in
pathology harmonization and I'm sort of
fairly passionate that the professions
got homework to do we can we can do
better when it comes to standardizing
the things that we do and some of those
groups down the bottom groups that I
work with so the AAC B is the
australasian Association of clinical by
chemists the RCP a is the Australian or
the australasian Royal College of
pathologists our pathologists group and
they've been running some pathology
standardization initiatives for a number
of years now and and I'm also currently
the chair of terminology group the I FCC
and are you paid committee from their
main clutches properties and units so I
just want to declare that up front
because I am going to be talking
particularly about Howie health any
health records are going to change
pathology as we know it and we're used
to being in control and pathology but I
think some of this stuff is going to
start taking us out of our comfort zone
and and different people have different
ideas about what a health is going to
look like and what it's going to do but
you know generally there's still an
awful lot of paper particularly in
hospitals even wear paper has been
replaced by electronic systems we really
don't do a great job of hooking those
systems together and some themes there
that I'll talk about later on
and I you know the financial world has
been doing this stuff for many years we
all take for granted that when we travel
around the world we're going to be able
to whip our credit card out pay for
whatever takes our fancy we really
haven't got anything like that
portability with with our health or with
our without pathology and the the
financial portability it didn't come
easily it happened over many many years
and there was a lot of work over the
last thirty even forty years to get the
computerized systems up to scratch so
many many countries have got a lot of
homework to do to to get to get going
with their eHealth and and I you know
we're all aware that everyone's health
systems are under pressure we're all
being told to do more with less and
pathology pathology is always finding
its budgets getting round back and I
certainly people that I've heard
presenter I've had the luxury of meeting
from around the world it's rare that
they've got enough money and enough time
to do all the things they want to do so
he health is something that the industry
and the politicians and everyone hopes
will will add some value so some themes
I'm going to be speaking about today and
I'll touch on why pursuing your health
is a good thing I'll talk a little bit
about what different countries have done
because our webinars give us the luxury
of being able to to talk internationally
and in my experience labs don't do a
great job of standardizing with the lab
down the road let alone standardizing
globally that's something that's
probably going to have to follow
eventually so what are the implications
for pathology and I said I'm mainly a
pathology Diagnostics person so so keep
that in mind if I'm a little bit biased
and I want to talk about some of the
tools of the trade that are available
and I guess in my experience people
don't always know about these tools
we're all busy being good pathologists
and scientists we don't always know
about the state of the art IT tools and
how to use them that someone else
problem but I would hope I've convinced
you by the end of this presentation that
it's something that pathology
professions actually got to have
ownership of so what's it going to mean
to all of us and hopefully I've made the
point now that there really is a lot of
unnecessary variation between laboratory
practice in my experience within cities
or within States or in countries most
organizations have actually done a
pretty good job of following guidelines
and standardizing what they do within
organisations and I know we've been a
lot of initiatives within the
laboratories that I operate within but
when you compare between labs there can
be some scary variation and I'd contend
to you that a health records are going
to mean that patients are going to see
their results they're going to want to
know what they mean and if someone
doesn't explain it to them they're going
to work out google and try and find out
themselves and sometimes that can be a
bit dangerous for us as well and and
when I talk about dangerous variation
this is just an example report from one
of the local standardization initiatives
it's not a real report it's just making
the point that we know within Australia
we've got labs that put the most recent
results on the the right hand side of
the screen the right hand side of the
report we've got other laboratories that
put it on the left hand side and it
drives our local clinic clinicians crazy
but I can't understand why we can't even
agree on something as basic as that it's
actually potentially quite dangerous if
you think about it if a patient's
getting worse the last thing that you
wanted someone reading the report back
the front so ideally we want a common
language for the tests that we order and
the test panels and I know within my
country and I suspect a lot of countries
the test panels the liver functions the
routine electrolytes the renal function
and also other panels iron studies etc
there's often a lot of confusing
variation between what laboratories will
perform when a clinician orders
test and I something else I see is that
pathology labs have actually seen that
as an advantage they feel that their
local experts should be able to put into
the report what they feel reflects their
knowledge however there's a bit of a
balancing act there between labs adding
value by doing something different
versus just doing nonsensical variation
which is really going to leave people
scratching their heads so we'll just
quickly whiz through a little section
I've got here on health and I think this
is obvious to do anyone who's familiar
at the area but we most developed
countries are dealing with rapidly aging
population a lot of chronic disease and
comorbidities to deal with so a patient
walks in the door is often very complex
to treat and just on the top right here
is a typical sort of population
distribution for a developed country in
1911 so mainly young people and survival
rates meant that by the time we got into
70s and 80s there weren't a lot of us
left around below that is a colored
graph of men and women in Singapore and
that's projected a few years into the
future but people have described that
so-called coffin shape where there's
going to be this bulge of people in
their 50s and later which is really
going to stress out our health system so
we know that we're going to have some
major challenges as we move into the
future any health promises more portable
records better outcomes better safety
and I'll touch on some of these things
from the point of view of the clinician
and the patient so the patient hopefully
would expect to get better access to
their records and certainly that's a bit
of a novelty in Australia it's actually
been relatively tricky to get a copy of
your results you can write in and get
one but most people don't bother jumping
through the hoops in Australia so I
think it's one thing we've noted is that
patients are generally quite keen to see
their results and they're curious but
they also want to have more control they
would expect to get better services in
terms of billing making appointments and
prescriptions there's the hope of online
support
which is great for regional areas but
adds an extra complexity to the
doctor-patient relationship if it's not
necessary and as evidence to suggest
patients will pay a little bit more for
these services that's not always a big
thing that people forget sometimes is
that we know there's a lot of medical
errors happening and any health offers
the promise of reducing that if we could
even reduce those errors just a little
bit that would make a huge huge benefit
to the patients and also benefit to the
financial systems there's also a risk
however when you're designing software
that you won't get a quite right and
there have been documented cases in the
literature like this reference down the
bottom here where people have actually
ended up treating patients incorrectly
based on miss reading the information
and the health record and that's
obviously not a good situation so
clinicians want to make sure that
they're understood they don't really
want their patients being too educated
if it's anecdotal information they'd
prefer that it's evidence-based it can
be difficult if you're dealing with a
patient who's not physically at hand it
costs time and money for four surgeries
hospitals clinicians in many settings to
to set themselves up to deal and to
learn how to deal with this technology
and the software and there's always the
issue of security for the patients and
the doctors and that's that's a major
concern and the online environment so
you may have heard recently ebay was was
hacked and they really don't know how
much information was lost and so it
wouldn't be a good look if if the local
government a health record was was
hacked so most governments are spending
a lot of time and money on making sure
that doesn't happen and there's medico
legal issues and and the medico legal
issues aren't just with the new
processes it's also we find in the
pathology arena when we start talking
about standardizing a common concern i
get if we get a an influential member of
a pathology discipline to
to the table one of the questions
they'll often ask first is what's the
worst-case scenario if I get this wrong
and without fail I can generally
convince them that we know there's so
much variation already in pathology
systems that they can't really anything
they do is going to make things better
but there is the risk of a medico legal
action governments would like to see
things run more efficiently and be
cheaper they'd like that there isn't
much political fallout they've got the
the problem of trying to keep everyone
happy which adds dangerous complexity
and it's not a good thing when you start
an IT project with complexity ideally
you want a rock-solid business case that
everyone's going to use and then build
on that that's not always the way that
these things start out and you've got to
figure out which horse you're going to
back and here you go to sponsor so I'm
going to whisk through some countries I
it's probably going to be a very cursory
overview but I'm just going to go
through and have a look at a snapshot of
some various countries and just glancing
at the email addresses of some of you
that are online at the moment as I
expected a lot of you are based in
America but I think we've we've had a
couple of people from overseas popped in
and out so forgive me if I don't talk
about your country or if I don't give
your country enough coverage but it's
probably fair to say a lot of countries
and Australia is no different have
really struggled to get good policy in
place to do it wells expensive there's
resistance to change for a lot of
reasons it can be a dangerous political
exercise and sometimes people are left
wondering if it really is worth the
trouble to get on the horse and try to
ride it so I thought it would be
interesting just to touch on some of the
success stories and and some of the
places that these programs have got
bogged down so in developing nations we
know that many developing nations have
actually had the opportunity to to
leapfrog an entire generation of
communications infrastructure and and
there's a hope that some of the leverage
these countries are getting off
smartphones will pay
in the the e health and health arena so
there's been some some clever projects
in in some countries around common
morbidities like diabetes age support
nutritional planning and and certainly
some of these countries have put in
place payment options with mobile phone
infrastructure that challenge or surpass
what's available in developed countries
so it's not always a valid assumption
that developing nations are behind us
they've got access to the latest
technology even if their budgets aren't
all lasers as great in Europe there's
actually some really good examples of
eHealth that's being well governed and
is making a difference for patients and
clinicians so I'm aware personally the
czech republic and the scandinavian
countries are particularly active and
some of my work with the the npu
terminology organization that i
mentioned earlier brings me in contact
with with Danes and other Europeans and
it's impressive what they've achieved in
over a period of time so certainly in
Denmark there's been active initiatives
for many years and they've succeeded in
getting standards and good terminology
in place they're getting leverage
they've got very good governance from
their government organisations and
they've had online portals which are
being used throughout the the the health
system regularly for a number of years
since the mid-2000s and there's been
speculation why that's the case that
there is a slightly smaller population
it's easier to get the key movers
together the populations generally IT
savvy and and probably it's been a huge
help that that has been the population
has accepted being given a number and so
either a registry number or personal
identification numbers so that makes it
a lot easier to have centralized systems
and know that who you're dealing with
it's not something that is readily
accepted I know in Australia and I'll
talk about that in the moment people
have resisted me
given a number in the UK there are some
good initiatives in place it's my
understanding that they don't go into a
lot of depths in terms of the clinical
information which is available to the
patient and the clinician however there
has been a move to at least get
demographics available so that as you
move through the health system that
basic information is available in more
recent years there's been audits and
concerns that for all the money invested
there hasn't been a lot of positive
outcome and so certainly I think the end
it's fair to say the NHS is probably
still struggling to come up with a
really waterproof implementation I I
don't know a lot about the US but I
believe that there's been moves in lots
of areas for over many years but there
hasn't been a coordinated health plan
since 2009 there's a lot of money being
planned into Obamacare and other
initiatives has been incentives for
medical practitioners to to move into
the medical software arena but probably
it's fair to say security and privacy
conflicts and concerns between state and
federal law and patients and clinicians
have been an issue to deal with and I
said online from Australia and so
hopefully you can understand my broad
Ozzy accent but we've had particular
challenges getting started there's
there's frustration in Australia that
we've been talking about a lot of
initiatives for many years and we're
struggling to get to really get too far
down the road for the last 18 months
we've had the so-called PCEHR a
personally controlled health record
available and we've had a governance
from a government organization the
National eHealth transition authority we
haven't been able to convince people to
to receive a smart card which identifies
them for the health system there was a
concern that that was going to be too
big brother-ish and the government would
have access to too much information from
coordinated databases if we did that so
we do have the PCEHR but it's an
din system and most Ozzy's have decided
that they couldn't be bothered and they
haven't opted in that's a very broad
generalization and there's thousand many
thousands of these things hundreds of
thousands of them have been set up but
we're struggling to get critical mass of
this thing so we've had a major review
in recent months which was only released
very recently and it's identified the
fact that probably our opt-in model
should change to an opt-out to encourage
more people there needs to be a better
emphasis for clinicians and patients on
the benefits and emphasizing the
security possibly even to the extent of
people receiving an SMS to say that
someone is accessing their health record
so you can check whether that's
appropriate or not I I should warn you
that I'm going to to to talk about
initiatives in Australia quite a bit
because that's obviously my area of
expertise but I'm led to believe that
some of the things we've done our
typical of other countries and where
they're not if someone gets a good idea
well that's productive as well so we've
been active since the 90s with with
interchange formats for pathology which
have actually been quite successful and
and so successful they've proved a
little bit difficult to unwind as I said
meter came online in the mid 2000s and
towards the end of the 2000s and the
last few years we've had a number of
standardization initiatives and I'll
talk about these a little bit more later
but you'll hear me talking about puts
and pinus and this is the pathology
units and terminology standardization
program in 2011 and a follow-up project
for pinus in 2013 where and I was added
in for information pathology information
terminology and units standardization
I'll touch on those in more detail later
but I am now going to go into pathology
in more detail I'm going to talk about
these things this is probably the crux
of my talk and what needs to be done who
can make it happen who pays for it what
tools have we got and as I said earlier
I find most
pathology laboratory ins don't always
have a good grip on what tools are out
there so I'd like to talk about those
and our apologize if if that's too basic
a level but i often find people
intelligent people and pathology unaware
of basic I tool and Andy health
communication tools and what's going to
happen in the future with these systems
so so let's have a look at what needs to
be done but we know that what we've got
it may not be state-of-the-art and we
know we want to make it better and it's
not always about the technology it's
it's often more about getting the right
people in the room getting them talking
around the table agreeing to standardize
on the how data is coded and agreeing to
change their systems over to the new
super duper fast railway and anum
pathology we know we've been IT savvy
for a long period of time we had to be
that II health should help us get rid of
the paper reports that we still generate
for some people electronic requesting
would cut out a huge layer of manual
interpretation of scribbles on pieces of
paper and in Australia we're starting to
get a much higher level of electronic
requesting as much as fifty percent in
some of our laboratories but i know in
europe they've got much much much higher
levels of electronic requesting some of
the sonic labs in other countries on the
other hand have got very low levels of
electronic requesting and those those
laboratories would have a lot to gain
from from Rudy health systems electronic
reporting offers printers can be a very
expensive thing to maintain on networks
in terms of consumables and the software
so it would actually be very helpful for
pathology is to produce electronic
results and it also offers the
possibility of novel novel mechanisms
for reporting these things there's
traditionally a high investment in IT
and pathology laboratory so it is a good
place to get leverage in the health
system however pathologists aren't
always invited to the table but the
reality is that a lot of the health
system relies on pathology and we
probably need to speak up for ourselves
and learn to to sell ourselves better to
government
it isn't always best to be first with IT
and sometimes it's better to just sit
back and see it so ideally many of us
would like to be in the middle of the
herd and that makes it a little bit
difficult when you're talking about
initiatives for change because people
know that it takes time and money to
change but I would suggest to you and I
have talked more about it later that
we're going to be forced to change
faster than me we might wish to buy
clinicians and patients that are asking
difficult questions if we don't start
getting our heads together and investing
some effort into these things and I said
before that there's a lot of variation
and pathology reports clinicians are
often used to that and they get reports
from different practices they get used
to liking a certain type of report from
a certain practice the patients are not
always so used to that and they're
probably the ones that will be asking
more questions so one of the concerns I
often see with pathologists is that the
risk that pathology is going to be
reduced to a commodity and the IT guys
say look you know we've been sending
these results around electronically for
a long time we can do this it's not that
difficult but there's a lot of
complexity in pathology sometimes that
isn't immediately obvious and it's it is
a danger that people can make
assumptions about how this data can be
re represented taking from an atomic
piece of data putting it into a database
where you're combining results from many
laboratories and you can get some
difficult situations that make the
original laboratory uncomfortable if
they haven't had a say in how the
electronic health record assembles those
results it would be very helpful however
if laboratories were doing basic things
the same and I'm going to talk more
about some specific things here and this
is an Australian bias because we're
doing work in these areas currently but
I'd be interested to hear from some of
you and the question-and-answer session
towards the end if you're aware of some
local initiatives or you've got some
feelings about these things
I know I said before with test profiles
there's two big problems one is that
laboratories have different ideas about
how big a profile should be and what
tests are essential and there's
obviously monetary concerns there
there's also an issue that many
laboratories probably do more tests and
they need to and we've painted ourselves
into a corner to a certain extent where
it can be difficult to to take away
these tests clinicians aren't always
happy when you take away a test like
chloride for example which may add very
little value in most patients but you'll
always get a complaint from someone who
is looking for their chloride I'm going
to talk about formatting of results and
the variations in how reports are
represented I'm going to talk about
reference interval standardization and
documenting reference intervals some
concepts around whether it's safe to
combine are not combined results into a
health records and and touch on
so-called critical risk results because
many people don't realize that pathology
reports nowadays rarely flag critical
results there have been initiatives in
many countries around the world and a
little bit of a bias and some of those
things that I've thrown up from the
Australian New Zealand area but there
was some some excellent work done in
Europe over many years the Nordic
reference interval project norib dates
back to year two thousand and
Scandinavians are very sort of
nonchalant about some of the fantastic
work they did standardizing their
reference intervals as far back as the
end of last century so I know in
Australia we're getting close to
standardizing some tests I know in the
UK pathology harmony has been doing some
good work in recent years in Australia
we've had at least one annual scientific
conference which was devoted to the
topic of harmonization and
standardization these logos down the
bottom relate to the Peters project that
I talked about before which runs off
government money
the New Zealand people have had some
very good terminology standardization
projects over many years so I'll just
keep moving and I really do need to
confess that I'm an Aussie and I'm
probably going to be a bit biased about
some local initiatives so you'll have to
put up with that and as I said I'd be
happy to hear from you if you've got
some comments or whatnot later but but
hopefully the themes that I talked about
will have some interest to to those of
you from elsewhere in the world so yeah
grab a beer and a sausage and we'll see
where we go there was recently a
harmonization workshop in Sydney
Australia that I attended and this was
the third meeting we've had in recent
years aimed at trying to get
laboratories around Australia to use
standardized reference intervals and we
know from previous years that a
surprisingly large number of
laboratories are willing to change what
they currently use to a recommended set
of harmonized Australian values we've
got very good data from private large
private laboratories like sonic that I
work for but also a priori studies that
have been done from the ground up with
healthy patients and one of the key
studies was done in Canberra and and
that and they've come back with data
which was remarkably close to some of
the data mining results that we got from
our private pathology databases and I've
talked about the variation that we see
in reports but when it comes to two
reference intervals the tests that we've
looked at standardizing in Australia are
the electrolytes creatinine some of the
minerals and just a few enzymes in total
protein and we feel that we can do all
of those things with relatively little
fuss there's been a little bit of rgrg
about what is a reasonable potassium
interval and which laboratories may have
pre-analytical issues but in general
probably we would hope by the end of the
year there will be many Australian
laboratories moving to standardize
reference intervals for the
things and you'll be able to read about
that either on a a CB or the RCP a web
sites where there's some standardization
initiatives underway what we actually
what we understand in laboratories by
this column on the right hand side here
that's not always on the right hand side
even but these these we know they're not
normal ranges that's evil calling in
that but most of us now call in
reference intervals and and pathology
people know that there's actually a lot
of different numbers that pop up in
those columns there's population limits
there's decision limits from experts
astera pubic values for drugs and
sometimes there's other more complex
information that you want to link to we
probably don't explain that very well
currently and that's something that we
need to educate our end-users about and
it could be that novel electronic
mechanisms let us do that wave your
mouse over something and more
information it comes up in the
background but certainly in Australia
we're trying to just clarify to some of
our IT and patient groups that there's
actually a fair degree of complexity
hidden in that column and in fact we've
also asked laboratories or we will ask
laboratories when we soon put out our
recommendations that that column should
probably just have a single word above
it they should just say reference rather
than the rest interval or all the many
other variations we've got there's been
some very good local work surveying
pathology laboratories to get evidence
on the variations that we have and and
one of the things we've seen is that we
now know that the standardization of our
patient results is generally very very
good for those tests that I showed you
before however embarrassingly when we
look at our reference intervals because
of the use of historical limits and it's
time-consuming and expensive to
determine a good reference interval
because of that often for routine
biochemistry tests we know our Rangers
have more variation in them than the
analytical standardization in the in the
test wouldnt would it would make you
think so we can meet we can reliably
measure a potassium to point one point
however variation in our reference
intervals is often as much as point 5 or
point 8 millimoles I won't go into this
in detail but there was a good paper
from siced NL that talked about these
concepts and it's probably a good thing
for you to send patients or clinicians
off to and they don't understand some of
these terms around deriving reference
intervals that we spout we're going to
put some recommendations out in
Australia around things that seem basic
to people that use pathology reports all
the time but we know there is some
variation between labs and we're going
to say reference intervals should be
inclusive that is if you've got a
reference interval of 5 to 20 you should
be flagging values a 4 or below or 20 21
and above you should have the same
number of significant figures for your
results as you do for your patience and
the flagging should be based on that as
well you shouldn't be looking to
normalize your results you shouldn't be
looking to see if you're halfway down
the reference interval or nine percent
through the reference interval because
of the variation in intervals we know
that's not a good idea there's
difficulties in how you describe
partition so for those laboratories that
have very good pediatric values or
pregnancy values and have invested time
and effort into getting those it's
actually surprisingly difficult to
describe them and I won't dwell on this
but we've been debating some different
ways of describing these things without
resorting to too many less than great
events and mathematical symbols and our
final terminology will probably be a bit
cleaner than that but I would be
interested to know of anyone who's found
a perfectly safe way of saying what 1 2
3 years of age means does that mean your
3rd birthday or the entire third year of
your life and I know that too
intelligent people can be standing right
next to one another and have completely
different concepts in their head for
what one two three years means and both
be convinced that they're correct and
that's something that we can't tolerate
going into the future we need to all be
thinking and documenting the same way
there's a lot of variation and flagging
and a won't touch on this but some
people use asterisks some people use
bold some people use
then needs to be some sort of local
agreement on what is reasonable and I
won't dwell on that too long but with a
lot of variation in Australia with units
there have been some good initiatives
around drugs in Australia saying that we
should all now use gravimetric units and
that's miffed a lot of people had gone
to effort to use SI units which we
routinely use for pathology in Australia
however there was an expert group with
not just pathologists that looked at
this and felt that there's a very good
argument for not using molar units so
you're welcome to to look up that paper
in the medical journal of Australia if
you wanted to see more about why we did
that formatting of results is an area
that again this huge variation between
laboratories I won't dwell on this other
than to comment that even in terms of
rounding there can be some silly
variations i often find scientists in a
laboratory i'm embarrassed to say them
will dilute and mlas one in a hundred or
one in a thousand and and seem happy to
report it as 120 3507 and I sort of
asked them if they're really sure about
the seven units per liter so we probably
don't do a good job on standardizing our
rounding and that's just the tip of the
iceberg I'm just going to touch on
so-called critical results and experts
on critical or critical risk results can
spend all day arguing about the
terminology for them but certainly in
Australia where get soon going to put
out some guidelines on what we feel the
basics for how people should handle
critical results generally most
laboratories in Australia don't flag
these on reports we rely on some sort of
follow-up override method and that's
generally a phone call which is
documented in our la essence that we've
reached someone we've communicated that
a lot of result is potentially
life-threatening or it's going to have a
lot of impact on the future treatment of
the patient and we make note of that so
there's a group in Australia which is
working on some consensus guidelines and
I believe in America clsi is close to
putting out some guide
lines on critical results as well which
is probably worth being on the lookout
for Oh much of what we've done in
Australia has really been focused on
getting basics in place for paper
reports and we probably should have done
it a long time ago but at least we're
doing it now people often say to me well
you know we're in the electronic era now
isn't this a bit old-hat you really need
to come up with recommendations that
work in both arenas and it may well be
that in the future we'll do other clever
things but we have to get the foundation
stones in place before we can build on
those something which we've done a
little bit of work in Australia but we
recognized early on was a problem when
you start combining results from
different laboratories is is it safe to
combine the the troponin result from the
laboratory down the road the troponin t
with the troponin and I from the public
hospital up the road and of course if
it's a different analyte and you
shouldn't put them on the same line in a
report but if it's the same analyte but
a different immunoassay manufacturer you
can have some fairly exciting variations
in standardization of the results how
the essays respond to the sample itself
and it's quite a challenge sometimes to
figure out if two assays give similar
patient results and even if they do for
normal patients they may not do it for
abnormal patients and so we've we've
started the process of trying to find
answers to some of these questions in
Australia we've put out some very rough
guidelines for about 70 or 80 tests but
we've recognized that this is going to
be a potentially time-consuming
difficult exercise in the future that's
something that does need to be dealt
with so we we've actually taken a leaf
out of the English harmonization program
and stolen their traffic light system
which we think has got a lot of benefit
and we flag tests that we know would be
dangerous tumor markers are often a good
example of that tumor markers can have a
lot of variation between
for an immunoassay so most of those we
have flagged as red green is things that
we know we've got information whether
qap or reference interval studies or
bias studies that shows that you've got
very good agreement between laboratories
and there are some analytes where that
is the case and they can be flagged
green but the ugly reality for us in
Australia and I suspect a lot of
countries is that the vast majority of
pathology tests probably fall into this
we just don't know category and we've
got a lot of homework to do there I
won't dwell on that because I'll
probably need to get through my slides a
bit faster so I think I've got that
concept across but one point I want to
make is this is an area that the
pathologist's need to show leadership
whether solid medical pathologists or
our laboratory scientists there's a lot
of complexity in pathology which is an
obvious to IT people to clinicians or
patients who don't measure things for a
living and we probably need to do a much
better job of communicating that
complexity one way of doing it is the
traffic light system or I mentioned so
who makes these changes happen in
Australia we've got lots of bodies with
logos some of these are overseas groups
but the reality is to get good standards
you need input from lots of different
professional groups so you need people
from the different disciplines within
pathology but you also need experts from
outside pathology and you need probably
patient representation clinicians
government representation if you're
trying to get government money medical
software vendors like to know what's
going on because their livelihood
depends on these things so the more of
these people you have around the table
the greater the likelihood that the
recommendations will be accepted there's
also obviously a greater chance that
you'll get bogged down and complexity so
provenance is and governance are very
important principles in this arena you
need the right people who people will
recognized in the profession and so if
you've got someone with reasonable
amount of clout then if guidelines put
out with their name on it hopefully
laboratories will follow and we've seen
that happen in Australia with some of
the harmonization work that we've done
we've had some very senior people from
our pathology yum pathology advisory
committees and people do seem to have
taken notice you need IT experts to
explain to the pathology people how the
IT systems work and they need to be able
to communicate and you need a
willingness for people to get involved
and you also need people to be willing
to follow up regularly and look at how
goalposts are changing so I'm not going
to spend much time on these Australian
groups i've mentioned nita there's a lot
of laboratory scientific groups in
Australia and to differing extents
they've tried to to do work in the
health arena and it's generally not
incredibly well accepted the only way
we've got good runs on the board in
recent years was by all of the
scientific societies and I'm most
heavily involved with the biochemistry
society which happens to be listed at
the top maybe that's all fanatical or
maybe embarrassed that I'm I'm from the
AAC be but I recognized that I'm not
going to get my message across unless I
join the broader arena of our college
pathologists which represents all of the
pathology disciplines and they're the
people that have got the best links with
government and so people listen when
they put out guidelines so in recent
years any guidelines that any of the
scientific societies have contributed to
and many of the societies have slotted
into these programs we end up putting
our guidelines out with stamp on it not
just the our CPA but as many of the
other groups involved as we can I'm not
going to dwell on how some of these
guidelines were developed I think I'll
just keep the pace up and move through
this i mentioned that we've had a couple
of programs which seemed to be getting
results Titus the follow-up program
which is still currently running is
scheduled to put out guidelines within
the next few months in a number of
arenas around the requesting and
reporting of pathology and it's also got
some government money to reward people
that except the guidelines and start
using them so what tools do we have to
to get out good health pathology results
and I've used that railroad analogy I'm
going to touch on a concept called
interoperability which I find some
people know about and often pathology
people don't and railways is and a good
analogy we for many years in Australia
we had states that actually had railways
that looked like this rather than
standardize on something between states
we knew that when a train across the
border it was going to be a different
size so in this crazy system where we're
trying to do two or three different
types of railways at once you don't want
to be doing that so the first problem
you have when you transmit information
between people or systems is you need to
be able to transmit the information
that's so called technical
interoperability and in health messaging
that's done with the hl7 system and you
won't be able to read that message but I
encourage you to read about hl7 if you
want to know more about the basic
messaging level more important to us as
pathology people are semantic
interoperability and this is making sure
the meaning of the message is understood
and good terminology allows us to
communicate information between computer
systems whether they're lis Azure or
hospital laboratories effectively you
don't want to be mapping a couple of
thousand terms from laurell is at to
multiple computers it's a lot of work if
you do it through a common terminology
then if everyone's speaking the same
language it should save a lot of work
and so turn good terminology lets you
not only describe disease and pathology
but it also lets you request and code
data in a very useful form for later the
concepts of pre and post coordination
are important so I don't know if you're
aware but pre coordination is we have a
terminology which describes complex
relationships
with a single term such as a test
24-hour urinary creatinine would have a
single term which describes it post
coordination is where you individually
describe these terms and you can
catenate together for mathematical terms
that describe them into a single
relationship so you end up with a much
bigger term that you've got more power
to code a big problem with pre
coordinated systems is that you can very
rapidly get a so-called combinatorial
explosion of terms and you don't want
too many terms otherwise you're
increasing the chances that different
laboratories will be using different
terms I I want to just quickly touch on
the fact that there are three
terminologies sno-med is a monster
terminology for coding medicine low ink
is the probably the most popular
pathology coding system around the world
and I would be remiss if I didn't
mention the npu which was run out of the
I FCC and I you pack and is one of the
older terminologies but probably not as
well funded as some of the others I
haven't got time to go through the
slides I've put in here about these
terminologies but I would encourage you
to go and read about sno-med low ink and
the npu if you're not already familiar
with these terminologies but they vary
in terms of how they describe terms they
vary in how challenging it is to develop
local code sets to constrain people from
having to too much variation in their
codes in Australia we had problems with
individual laboratories selecting items
and then later on we realized we had an
awful lot of variation because we hadn't
discussed the codes that we are
developing so we're now working hard to
try and remove that variation the npu
terminology is probably unusual and that
it's it's one of the terminologies which
references each term in the database
back to other databases and certainly
because we've got access to the
resources of our you pack and are you
pack does databases very well because
there are people that run the periodic
table for example but they also have
very quick
ecology links so these some of these
terminologies differ in how well their
terms are developed and some of the
definitions are very ad hoc or some of
the other terminologies are founded in
very sound scientific principles and
they and there's variations in how easy
it is to read these things between
countries sometimes as well but the last
big area that I'm going to touch on is
who's going to maintain these systems
and how do we develop them and I've just
got some slides here suggesting to you
that it's on volunteer work it's either
government funded or a mixture or user
pays and user pays isn't always terribly
successful in this arena I've talked a
lot about the Australian of the
Australian situation where we do have
cross-disciplinary groups and we found
that that was the only way to get
success in developing these things but
it's not it's not something that you do
once that it's done forever the evidence
base is constantly growing and changing
and we need to update these terms as we
go I won't dwell on combine do not
combine again so I'd suggest to you that
to get a really good product it needs to
be easy to use and iPhone took off
because it was easy to use and kids know
how to use it when you give them one but
it isn't a given that programmers will
always right great any health software
so the end users the patients the
clinician's but also the pathology
people need to be involved in this
process and i know in australia many of
our software vendors have put little
clever tricks in because they know that
terminology currently isn't mature
enough to describe terms that are
regularly reported in Australia I
another concept that is important is the
fact this isn't a straight line the fact
that you as hard as you try to get a
group of experts in the room and
eventually get them to agree on
something off limits of its perrito
principle works not worth trying to get
a hundred percent agreement on something
more often than not what you're dealing
with is an incremental process where it
might feel you're going around in
circles but in fact over a period of
years you build on new technologies new
standards as they come online and the
JCT Ln the Joint Committee for
traceability in laboratory medicine is a
fantastic standardization initiative
that wasn't available twenty years ago
30 years ago and without it we wouldn't
have got as far as we have with a lot of
standardization work nowadays so that's
an example of something that has become
an important prerequisite I think for
those of you who are online and
pathology laboratory people you know
that you don't just automate something
and expect that you like a machine in an
automated existing process you you
actually have to put a lot of thought
into getting the best out of the next
generation of technology I must be
getting all because I can see that smack
pictures reversed but as as these things
come online you have to standardize the
tubes that you've got you have to
standardize the process for how they're
sent through the laboratory and you have
to work on your IT systems to make these
things happen and it's going to be the
same for pathology laboratories in the
eHealth arena we're going to have a lot
of questions asked of us and I think
some of them are going to be
embarrassing if we haven't got our heads
together so hopefully I've convinced you
that there's a lot of initiatives
underway in many countries that show
great promise hopefully I've I've also
convinced you that there is a lot of
benefit in pathology in getting involved
in those initiatives it's there's good
reasons why pathology professionals need
to be communicating the complexity and
the disciplines that we work in but we
also need to be learning about IT and
and what our customers want and I think
historically we've probably been a
little bit too quick to tell the
customer what they need rather than
listen to what they want so I would
argue that there's never been a better
time to look at harmonizing and
standardizing pathology I talked about
the JC tlm and some of the fantastic
initiatives the diagnostic industries
and the profession have have come up
with but will only get maximum benefit
from that when everyone's playing
together in the same sandpit so just my
final slide any health is accelerating
in most countries patients and
clinicians are going to come up with
questions we're going to need to respond
to that and it's going to happen in many
areas at once it'll be interesting but
challenging it'll be time consuming and
expensive but it should be worthwhile
but it will also require a constant
input to maintain so I've probably
talked a little bit long there so I'll
I'll just finish up on that slide and
I'll hand over to the question and
answers session so I would encourage any
of you who've got any any comments to
make from from your country or any
questions about my presentation to to
have a go and type in some questions on
your screen there and hopefully the
organizers will help me sort out any
questions that come up and we'll have a
look at them so um that's the end of my
slides and at this stage I haven't seen
anyone hit me with any questions so
that's making it very easy for me to
have an answer for everyone's questions
and thank you for all of you who came
along today I should also take time out
to thank the bio conference organizers
for asking me to present so certainly
this is my first experience giving an
international webinar and I hope those
of you that listened in found it useful
and if any of you have managed to get
some decent ideas for local initiatives
then I'll have succeeded in my my
mission today I can see just looking
down the screen here that we we do seem
to have representation from quite a few
different countries so so that's good to
see
so if we're getting to the end here and
there aren't any questions then I'm
probably going to close up shop soon but
again I would just encourage you if
you've got any questions don't be shy
please type them in but otherwise we'll
be closing up in in five or six minutes
or maybe sooner
and I mean if you haven't got a question
for me I would be curious to to hear
from anyone who has had some interesting
work in this area so please feel free to
share any comments that you've got I
believe the the slides from the
presentation will will get put up and be
available for all the next few weeks or
a couple of months so if you want to
share these slides or any other
presentation with someone you're welcome
to to look those up on the by conference
website and and have a look and go from
there so look I don't think I've got any
questions so Jen if you're still there
in the background I probably will close
up shop at this point in time and again
I'd like to thank everyone for taking
the time to listen in on my presentation
and I hope that you got some value from
it have a good day everybody